it's funny when when you're making lots
of money it's like admirable it's
respectable it's like look those are
traits we want but when you're not
successful you know you're a lunatic I
have extreme Obsession to the point
where like for me it's much easier to
think about something 16 hours a day for
seven days straight than it is like to
like gear shift constantly I'm like
really good at just obsessing over one
thing more than anyone else on the
planet if I were to say what's my
superpower it's that I can just obsess
endlessly about something and I can just
have the same thoughts over and over and
over and over again it's it's very weird
like it wasn't like it was work for me
grinding YouTube for those 10 years or
whatever where no one was really
watching it it's just like kind of who I
am